why do we age it's a simple question
without of yet a simple answer
now there are many theories of Aging it
is
like there's lots of information
well three things I found myself doing a
lot these past few weeks includes
thinking about how different scientists
are defining aging reading very rare and
old biology books and thinking of silly
things to write in a YouTube script in
this video we'll stick with the first
two the latter being a given of course
now with these different theories of
Aging I do have separate videos talking
about many of them but I felt like we
needed an update and I said some recent
not so like reading I've been doing so
in this video will consider what is the
current major thoughts regarding why we
age and consider whether aging as
programmed or if aging is loss of
entropy so we'll cover a lot so
and so the Story begins when I was on a
train on a Friday evening and began to
read this book how life began a
speculative study in Modern Biology
written by David Forsyth and published
in 1939
speculative by name speculative by
Nature this is what I wrote after
reading it and I mean naturally with a
provocative title like this a lot of the
book was spent defining what is meant by
life which along with why the age is
another one of those big questions
and also what is nature versus nurture
or heredity versus environment is by
Forsyth spends most of his discussion
ultimately he concludes that we are in
an intimate connection with our
surroundings no plant or animal can
exist without these external conditions
in the sense the environment suggests
itself as an essential part of every
organized being
we can also escape the conclusion that
functionally as well as spatially and
structurally living beings and their
environments merge and blend in such a
manner and to such a degree that there
is no separating them or isolating them
from each other they constitute Unity
so if we consider the bigger picture
just as what lies around an individual
cell is counted as sharing the
organism's life so the fluids that lies
around an individual plant or animal
should be reckoned a component of its
vital process
in this way the current idea of
biological life is expanded we conceive
of it as the joint attributes of both an
organism and its environment
life now becomes a property not only of
an organized structure but also others
outer worlds
and while I was making notes on this
book I started skim reading this article
the reality of Aging feuds from the
arterial wall
which without getting too Mata begins
any discussion about any aspect of Aging
cannot beg the issue of what aging is to
Edward Lakota the author of this
perspective article my view is that
aging is a shift in an organism's
reality
so what's reality this is another tough
question my view is that reality can be
comprehensively defined as a system of
mutual enslavement of DNA and its
environments if this appears to be a
naive assessment of reality check out
what constitutes the DNA environment
he explains a bit in this video here and
as we get older all of those
interactions that DNA environment system
starts to fail in those interactions
among all of those layers of environment
and our DNA becomes different and we can
now measure that it's sort of a a global
way of assessing who we are and what's
happening to us as we age
so ultimately
that age
80 construed as a series of failures of
the signaling within the DNA
environmental system
and because it's a fun sentence to say I
will repeat it reality is a system of
mutually enslaved DNA and its
environment
now this is beginning to appear quite
similar to the ideas that David Forsyth
was presenting in his speculative book
and you have to remember that in 1939
they they knew DNA existed but the link
of DNA being the hereditary material was
not fully understood and hence it's sort
of missing from Davis discussion
but they both had this deeper
appreciation of the interaction of both
the sort of living organism and its
external environments
anyhow the answer given is that the
robustness and flexibility of the DNA
environmental system is lost with age
but that still leaves us with the
question but why
now I was actually going to make a video
on these two texts alone but then I came
across a recent review article aging as
a software design floor and when aha
this sounds interesting given what I've
just been reading wouldn't it be fun to
add it to
and in this article the author proposes
that we age not because of inevitable
damage to the hardware but because of
intrinsic design flaws in the software
defined as the DNA codes that
orchestrates how a single cell develops
into an adult organism
now at first glance these two
definitions wanted to shift in an
organism's reality and one due to
Intrinsic design flaws may appear
disparates but as we'll see they are
more aligned than you may think so let's
dig deeper and discuss the arguments put
forward in this recent review
the first thing we should probably clear
up is what is meant by hardware and what
is meant by software Hardware here
encompasses all elements of biological
systems so not just DNA but all the
organs tissues the cells and the
structures so the mitochondria
telomerase proteins and so on
most of which have at some point been
hypothesized to be important in aging
on the contrary software is the genetic
program the DNA code that orchestrates
how a single cell becomes an adult human
being capable of reproducing ultimately
our evolutionary purpose herein I he
presents and explores the hypothesis
that perhaps aging is not a result of
inevitable wear and tear or accumulative
molecular damage in the hardware but
rather that aging is caused by Design
flaws in the software itself
simply put I hypothesize that the mouse
develops in ages 20 to 30 times faster
than a human being because its
developmental software program runs 20
to 30 times faster than in a human being
so what evidence is there to support
this hypothesis
what else first briefly introduced the
alternative hypothesis that aging is not
programmed the idea that aging is due to
stochastic damage and errors so this
includes theories such as the wear and
tear Theory the free radical Theory and
the accumulation of somatic DNA
mutations
that's it brief introduction over
now this review doesn't argue that
offense like these don't happen and
aren't important in particular there is
an entire section considering how cancer
is an exception to this idea
but instead that these features like DNA
mutations that aren't repaired are due
to failures in the software suggesting
that aging is not not programmed
so evidence number one to support the
theory that aging is programmed take a
good look at the spares
and then take a look at these two images
one shows the reflection of the right
side of the pairs one the left side they
look about the same they
if aging was due to random accumulation
of damage then why is hair graying
symmetrical that is what the authors of
this paper concludes
the results presented with aging of the
hair follicles of the male beards
indicate a symmetrical pattern of the
graying Parts on the left and right
sides
these findings suggest that graying
areas are not formed as random
distribution
now this is probably a weak line of
evidence albeit rather entertaining but
more compelling evidence comes from
considering DNA inflation a modification
or tag you may like to think of it that
can be added to side seam residues of
DNA if one tracks whether a certain
subset of these cytosine sea residues
have methylation or not and creates sort
of score for it many researchers have
observed that it correlates with
chronological age
irrespective of whether these
methylation changes are causal to aging
or just correlative
the surprising accuracy throughout
lifespan doesn't fit the idea that aging
is a product of entropy breaking down
the body
to quote Raj and hovath while the speed
of Asian Khan and is affected by
external factors the essence of the
aging process itself is an integral part
of and the consequence of the
development of life
this is what the review I'll go use and
these DNA inflation changes otherwise
referred to as DNA methylation clocks or
epigenetic clocks have been employed in
other studies to investigate the biology
of Aging most recently I discussed the
information Theory of Aging
the theory that Aging in eukaryotes is
due to a loss of transcriptional
networks and epigenetic information over
time driven by a conserved mechanism
that evolves to co-regulate responses to
Cellular damage such as a double strand
break or a crush injury
one of the key parts of this theory is
that epigenetic marks Unlike DNA
mutations are actually reversible
but as I discussed earlier this year in
this video the data for testing the
information Theory of Aging is pretty
sparse at the moment
and that could be because the
information Theory seems to be part of
the software and captures only some
aspects of the aging process
anyway speaking of this software we
haven't fully addressed what is meant by
a design flaw now I think we can all
grasp the concept of a design floor
but what does that mean when it comes to
aging
well the argument put forward in this
review is that the developmental
software program is comprised of a set
of instructions that triggered the
complex Cascade of offense that enable
us to develop from a single cell
the software is optimized for
reproduction and hence it may fail to
deactivate programs later in life that
become detrimental the provocative
support for this comes from considering
the relationship between sexual maturity
and lifespan across mammalian species
this strong positive correlation
suggests that the pace of Aging is
mechanistically linked to the pace of
development
and in fact there's even more recent
studies to support this idea that's
slowing down developments could increase
lifespan for example for deem's Gladys
Chef lab shows using genetically diverse
mice
that when the mice were given rapamycin
for the first 45 days a compound that is
thought to inhibit cell growth the
median lifespan was extended by 10 so by
slowing down this early developmental
stage
it increased the lifespan
so given this information it does seem
that maybe the instructions in the
developmental software later in life
leads to damage to the hardware
but to really be able to test and see if
this hypothesis is true we need to
define the changes in information usage
in cells that with age result in this
damage under the client function
so basically what are the examples of
this design failure well this made me
think of a recent paper I came across
on the dream complex
the dream complex is involved in
repressing
a subset of genes that are involved in
DNA repair mechanisms
and essentially the study suggests that
this dream complex represses these DNA
repair mechanisms in somatic cells but
not in germ cells again source of in
line with this idea we've been throwing
around
and it suggests that reactivating
repressed DNA repair mechanisms could be
a way to befriend aging and cells
moreover another random thought they had
that's worth considering is that some
proteins are
produced at lesser amounts after
development one being the protein
elastin that is purported to no longer
be expressed correctly after adulthood
elastin is an important component in the
skin and arteries in particular for well
elasticity unsurprisingly the protein is
purported to have a half-life of 70
years a long time but not a lifetime and
hence could be a reflection of what
would be defined as a software design
floor this repression of elastin
expression
so to summarize this little section one
major implication of the hypothesis
proposed here is that cells know how to
avoid molecular damage and aging but
because of the design flaws in the
developmental software they just stop
doing so later in life
what sees us onto phase three the
solution what can be done about this
how can we modify the software to
reactivate some of these repressed
programs
well one thing is to reboot the system
and one mechanism for this that seems to
be possible is so-called epigenetic
reprogramming reprogramming an a cell
entails restarting the software which
involves resetting the epigenome
and we know that this could be possible
one from the fact that
each new side goats starts fresh and you
know newborn babies aren't already
pre-ased to the age of their parents
and secondly that studies have employed
this cellular reprogramming approach
using the infamous yamanaka factors to
partially rejuvenated tissues in Old
mice
but it's important to State here that
even if we find ways to reboot the
system using epigenetic reprogramming it
doesn't guarantee that all aspects of
Aging can be reversed in this review
presbyopia as mentions this results from
overgrowth of eye lenses distorting
fission
and the author suggests that resetting
the developmental program may not
necessarily refer to the outgrowth
it's like how baking a cake
at least at the moment there's no way
that you can go back and you know regain
your initial ingredients
and so it basically suggests that
research at the moment should be trying
to understand what aspects are
reversible and whether or not it's a
matter of retracing the steps or whether
or not we instead Go full circle and
find an alternative route back
and so where do we go from here
well restarting or rewinding the
developmental software program to
rejuvenate sales and Achieve clinical
benefits and aged issues holds great
promise but will likely require a
considerable fine tuning as well as
tailoring to specific tissues and
degenerative processes to crack aging we
ultimately need to understand how
information encoded in the DNA sequence
and memorized in the epigenome instructs
a single cell to turn into an embryo
than a fetus that is later triggered by
genetic information to become a newborn
it grows to a child and adults and then
a subset of that information causes it
to degenerate age and die
the hopeful end is that importantly if
we age because of the softwares run on
rather than passive damage to the
hardware the most cellular aging changes
are reversible
information is suppressed not lost
during aging
so with that we've made it to the end of
this jam-packed video
if you enjoyed it then you might like
this video here whatever it may be
otherwise thank you to my patrons
Porters and thank you for listening